[Music]
an introduction to lambda a WS lambda is
part of Amazon Web Services compute
family of services AWS lambda was
announced at reinvent in November 2014
lambda became generally available in
April 2015 at the time of introduction
lambda only supported nodejs 0.1 0.36
AWS lambda now supports nodejs 4.3 to
Java 8 and Python 2.7 I would note that
nodejs 0.103 6 is deprecated and ends of
october 2016 you will no longer be able
to create functions using this version
of nodejs
what is lambda AWS lambda is a small
lightweight execution engine for a
single function instead of maintaining
and building a large fleet of ec2
instances and a large code base you
instead can write small specific
functions to perform the required tasks
lambda functions have two main execution
methods request response and event
request responses the method you would
use when you expect a response from a
request examples when integrating with
AWS API gateways an event execution
method is instead when you perform a
function based on a triggered event the
responses may be in the form of objects
stored in s3 or a document updated in
dynamodb
AWS has many integrations built into
many of their services a few examples
are here
AWS API gateway API gateway provides you
with a way to build api's that can be
backed by lamda to respond to HTTP POST
and get request api gateway is often
used with AWS Mobile SDK to build mobile
applications Amazon s3 s3 can provide
events when certain triggers occur which
can cause a lambda function to kick off
this can be used for such things as
resizing images AWS CloudFormation AWS
lambda can provide custom resources to
interact with either AWS services that
may not have confirmation support your
own tooling or other third-party
services AWS Kinesis lambda can be set
up to polar stream and read records of
the stream and do manipulations AWS
cloud watch events this integration is
best used for scheduling AWS functions
in a cron like fashion AWS dynamodb when
certain events happened within a table
of dynamodb you can kick off a lambda
function to manipulate that data
AWS SNS the AWS SNS service can have an
AWS lambda function as an execution
point for any message and can process
the payload as required
there are several other integrations
that AWS provides but we will be briefly
going through these ones later in the
course
how does lambda compared to traditional
stack a WS lambda is a highly scalable
service that provides reduced
administration costs and simplest setup
than traditional multi-tier application
strength comparing a traditional
three-tier architecture and lambda or
serverless application stack we can see
that there are significantly less
components to maintain this frees you up
to write code instead of managing
operating systems and infrastructure
configuration the benefits of the
traditional stack is its flexibility
because you are in control of the stack
you can build it the way you want and a
lot limited to AWS as you of course as
outlined this comes not only at a cost
of time but will also cost more to run
on the flipside AWS lambda or server
list stacks are very simple as much of
the complexity of managing and
maintaining the underlying
infrastructure is AWS is responsibility
and not yours this approach of course
has downsides one of which is you are
currently limited to only three
languages
AWS lambda is very cheap to run the
first one million requests per month are
free after that
AWS lamda costs 0.00001 six six seven
dollars per gigabyte chicken let's
briefly talk about how the pricing model
works lambda functions run in a
container like environment where you can
specify the amount of memory available
to the function you are then charged on
a per second basis per gigabyte time
frame memory settings start at 128
megabytes
and increment in 64 megabytes blocks to
1536 megabytes the maximum amount of
time a lambda function can run for is
300 seconds for five minutes
as with all AWS services there are other
certain limits that should be you should
be aware of you can only have up to 512
megabytes of a similar disk this is
based in /tmp this is not a variable you
cain't a deployment package or zip file
cannot be any larger than 15 megabytes
inside a payload in a request cannot be
any larger than 6 megabyte and you can
only have 100 concurrent requests at a
time some of the limits are available
review and increase by raising a support
case what are the some of the
difficulties you may run into while
deploying and creating your lambda
functions as AWS lambda and service
architectures are very new there are
some difficulties you may encounter and
the ecosystem is still very much
evolving versioning and deploying of
lambda functions can sometimes be
difficult there are tools and processes
both from AWS and third parties which
are starting to assist in these areas
prototyping and debugging can also often
be difficult again people are working on
solving these problems and as time goes
by the maturity of these systems will
increase
lastly AWS lambda is only available
today with three languages
while many discuss how to install and
use languages such as PHP and Ruby and
others have even gone as far as building
binaries using C++ or golang they aren't
strictly supported by AWS
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here